foreign
[Music]
Johnson and I am the owner of Aunt
Cheryl's Cafe located in Braddock
Pennsylvania what
happened when we came here is we became
a community Phenom we were able to bring
young people old people the police the
whole Community together just with our
location our location became a a spot
where people felt comfortable it became
a spot where people felt comfortable
enough to come here and talk about who
they are where people felt comfortable
enough to say you know I need a meal or
young kids felt comfortable enough to
come here and say I need a job you know
where the community felt comfortable
enough to be able to come in here and
say
you know I'm hungry and so we were
feeding the community we're serving the
community Through food and one of our
Specialties is our sweet potato pie and
what makes the world's best sweet potato
pie first you have to have good yams
okay you have to have cooked potatoes to
start with you have to have good
ingredients okay I can't give you
everything that I've put in it but
you also have to have can't put a little
love in it see our food is on Cheryl's
eyes our logo slogan is food made from
the heart so everything we do is made
from our heart so we put a little bit of
this we put a little bit of seasoning we
put a little bit of butter we put a
little bit of sugar most important thing
that we put in it as we put our hearts
in it so our sweet potato pie is the
best I've been all over the country I've
tasted it from coast to coast California
Detroit Philadelphia
offshore sweet potato pie the best don't
leave Brad it without one since we've
been here we've been able to expand that
building we've had posts we've had
Billboards all over town
promoting what we do here at on Cheryl's
Cafe and we do more than just feed the
people we serve the people